foreign
speaker
prime minister coloptia Robert
president of the National Council
honorable members of the National
Assembly of Slovenia
it is a great honor to address this
Noble House
although we gather here in dramatic
circumstances
in recent years I visited Slovenia
regularly
and I have enjoyed the incredibly beauty
of the landscape of its nature and the
amazing Hospitality of its people
so it breaks my heart to to see and to
be back on such a sad day
and to witness the full scale of the
devastation
Slovenia is known as The Sunny Side of
the Alps
but last week A month's worth of rain
fell over Slovenia in only one day
your idyllic Landscapes turned into a
hell of water and mud
not even this Alpine Paradise has been
spared by the impact of climate change
today I could see with my own eyes the
damage and the destruction caused by the
floods
the storm wrecked havoc in two-thirds of
Slovenia
the water has washed away all sorts of
critical infrastructure from Bridges to
electricity lines
thousands of families have been
evacuated
almost all businesses in the hardest hit
areas are affected
and tragically
six people have lost their lives
it is a national and a European tragedy
but against the force of nature
the people of Slovenia have reacted with
courage
and kindness
your response has been outstanding
an entire country has mobilized
in incredible speed
preventing an even greater loss of life
we were all moved by the images of
firefighters risking their own lives to
save 22 small children
from a flooded kindergarten
or by the scene of a young boy with a
blue
umbrella bringing snacks to a helicopter
crew
these are the pictures that will be
etched forever in our memory
and there are countless other stories
like these
every Slovenian has tried to help
everyone
volunteers have protected vulnerable
buildings with sandbags supermarkets
have offered food hotels have opened
their doors to evacuate people
let me borrow the words of the Delo
newspaper
and say
the whole fabric of Slovenian Society is
made of solidarity
end of quote
and I would like to thank each and every
Slovenian for that
Slovenia
this wave of solidarity has happened
under the outstanding leadership of
Slovenia civil protection
together with the whole government
and with local authorities this was
excellent cooperation and coordination
all political forces have come together
in a spirit of national Unity
and the results of this National
mobilization are already showing
I think for instance about those
Villages that have been completely cut
off from the rest of the country because
of the floods like cherna which I
visited today and I saw it with my own
eyes
I was told that cherna was for two days
it was impossible to reach the village
and even to communicate with residents
because of the lack of mobile connection
people didn't even know whether their
friends and family were alive
but then everybody mobilized to reach
out to the Village
Army and civil protection firefighters
and police Mountain Rescuers and Red
Cross
together with volunteers from all walks
of life
I saw it with my own eyes today and it
is impressive and heartwarming
they managed to bring food in by
helicopter to rescue the most vulnerable
to clean up the endless mud and then to
restore a road connection
thanks to their tireless efforts
they brought hope weather was only mud
this fast reaction has come as no
surprise for all of us in the European
Union
who have already seen Slovenian
solidarity in action
when your neighbors in Italy were struck
by floods
and when a devastating earthquake Quake
hit Croatia
Slovenia was among the first to send in
water pumps and rescue teams and this
has not been forgotten
you are also leading contributor to our
humanitarian efforts in Ukraine many
thanks for that
now I want to assure you
that all of Europe is with you in this
time of need
commissioner Leonard church was here
already during the weekend
to take part in an early emergency
meeting of your government
and today I am here to discuss concrete
ways for our Union to stand at the side
of slovenians
that was the content of our bilateral
talks with the Prime Minister today this
morning
as soon as slovenia's government called
for European support we activated the
Union Civil protection mechanism
eight member states responded to our
call within two days
they have already made available six
mobile bridges for helicopters 14
excavators all with relevant Crews to
help with the emergency
today for example in chernai I met with
teams from Austria from Croatia from
France from Germany who are already
working across the country
cleaning the debris with the excavators
and building emergency Bridges to
reconnect isolated areas
Europe is here for you
and we stand ready to assist with
anything you may need
Europe will also be by your side in the
coming weeks and months for the recovery
and the reconstruction
Slovenia can request and will receive
financial support from the European
Union
and we have discussed a package of three
components
first of all from the solidarity fund
400 million Euros are accessible
time is of the essence therefore the
European commission can pay an advance
of up to 100 million euros before the
end of the year
and then based on slovenia's request and
with the first damage assessment an
additional solidarity payment up to 300
million can follow next year
the second element
Slovenia could request an addition up to
2.7 billion euros under Next Generation
EU
this is fresh money
here two times of the essence
as you will have to make the request by
the end of August already this has
something to do with the procedures of
Next Generation EU
so I discussed with the Prime Minister
dear Robert that we immediately as of
today create a task force jointly
Slovenia and the commission to
fast-track the necessary assessment and
administrative work so that we make it
I'm confident till the end of the month
and then this money over time will be
accessible for you
on top of this we will also mobilize the
European agriculture crisis Reserve to
help farmers who have lost livestock
crops and machinery
we will find all possible ways to match
slovenia's proverbial solidarity
and finally the third element
we are looking at reprogramming existing
EU funds
and here I'm speaking in particular of
3.3 billion euros in cohesion funds for
Slovenia that can be used until 2027.
honorable members
prime minister dear Robert
during your speech to the European
Parliament last year
you said
when a community is United
and determined
then that Community can push the
boundary of what is possible
end of quote
this is true for Slovenia as well as for
Europe
and it is certainly true as we respond
to this Slovenian and European tragedy
I have not the slight doubt
that with Slovenian spirit
and with the confidence and courage and
endurance and stamina I saw today
impressive
and with Europe's support and solidarity
for our friend and member Slovenia
Slovenia once again will stand strong
will recover fast at the heart of Europe
Long Live Slovenia and Long Live Europe
thank you very much
foreign
[Applause]